hey guys welcome to the podcast how's it
going great cool
Kevin welcome back for people who don't
know you what do you do I'm a partner at
Y Combinator I founded a company called
wufu back in 2006 I was in the second
batch at YC and that company um
appropriately was a no office company we
were all remote all the way back then
huh that's relevant to today is that
some early inspiration Wow what are the
odds
all right Mike so what do you do yeah
I'm like um I am a co-founder of zapier
and we're chief product officer and I
originally started out as a front-end
engineer and a product designer so have
a very deep appreciation for those areas
and I think has kind of how I came to
run some of the design team today and
have thought a lot about like scaling
design teams over the last seven or
eight years and what is that Pierre do
zapier is a piece of software that helps
you automate your tasks at work helps
you be more productive so if you have if
you use multiple tools for your job and
you're trying to like you manual or
copying and pasting data from one tool
the other all day as part of like a task
you do you can use zapier to automate
that and have it done automatically in
the background mmm so an example would
be like if you are a let's say a project
manager and you've got a team that works
out of github and you wanted to like
send some notifications into slack or
into JIRA whenever those issues get
close you could set that up just as one
example cool and how did you guys meet
because you've known each other for a
while Kevin and I yeah yeah I came over
to the place that you guys were working
when you guys were doing YC and we just
like talked for a couple hours but it
was really interesting conversation
basically I told you is like this is
what we did at we foo and I was like you
should basically just do kind of a lot
of the same things and yeah yeah like
think about remote work that you're
gonna be doing this for a really long
time and then integrations was kind of
like you know patching a bunch of things
together to a form builder was like a
feature at we foo but to me I saw like
what they were doing was like turning
that into an actual business and so like
a lot of my insights were like this is
what works for us it's like really
powerful and I totally get why every
other company would kind of
interested in de pierre yeah you're
definitely one of the people who saw the
early
I think vision of what's a per could be
and form software is such a good use
case because the data it never ends in a
form you want to do something with it
usually it's once someone submits a form
I want to go put it my CRM or qualify
that lead or put them in an email with
somewhere it's actually interesting that
like I think the life cycle of people
like getting their business online it's
like you start off with like I need like
a presence it's like how do I get my
stuff out there and so use like website
builders like my default to become
really big we didn't realize this when
we started but we've understood this
later on was that like oh then people
need to figure out like how do I collect
data from all these people that are
coming to us and so form building
contact forms etc like all of that
became really relevant and surveys and
then the next thing is like oh and now I
have all this new data what do I do with
it and that's like zapier is like the
next step so these like the three like
stages of every company if like oh this
is what I need yeah and they have just
giant markets I remember early days we
foo people have talked to us about like
so what's your Tam what's like your
total addressable market and we
literally were just like I'm not doing
that because it'd be like have everyone
that ever has a website everyone who
needs to collect data like I do want me
to calculate that I have no idea yeah
and sometimes think those exercises
while useful are sometimes like a little
misleading it's misleading when your
market is so ridiculously large yeah
when you're thinking about like a
consumer adoption you don't ask Facebook
what's your tan right right and for us
we when we think about this opportunity
certainly when we got started you know
our ambitions were hey can we build like
a cool piece of software and support
ourselves but over the over the years I
think we realized whoa we've like tapped
into something that almost every person
who uses apps and software to get their
job done should be using something like
zapier there's just like excuse
explosion and SAS software in the
industry that is like the barrier to
entry to creating software is so low and
distributing software so low that you
get these niche tools and more and more
folks are using these niche tools and
bring them into the work place so if
something almost out of necessity has to
exist like zap your in order to be able
to make those tools play well together
and a lot of times just because of the
dynamics of the explosion and how many
tools there are there's no one player in
that marketplace that's going to be
incentivized to go build thousands of
integrations
everyone else yeah but if this point
want it yeah I mean at this point surely
you do have to be thinking more
specifically about personas and like
growing out individual markets right so
how do you approach it now that you have
you know so many users yeah honestly to
date it still is a very horizontal
strategy we have mostly focused over the
last seven years about getting more and
more apps on zapier and getting the
tools people went on zapier I think
that's been one of the things that
actually surprised me it wasn't how much
growth we've been able to get out of
like the initial I guess decision back
in 2012 to build an open platform
looking back that was definitely one of
the like better decisions I think we
made in the earliest we built the first
50 or 60 absent on zapier ourselves
bright way tonight just like bootstrap
that that engine and when we launched in
2012 we I remember we had live chat I
think a lark on the site at the time and
we you know I got literally we launched
in TechCrunch and had three days
straight where all the chat messages
were answering was just people asking
for apps that we didn't support and I
had never even heard of and it opened my
eyes and opened I think all over eyes
that if we're gonna get this thing to
scale we have to figure out a way to get
those apps on zapier and we just can't
do it with three people so we it was
almost out of necessity we don't have
money to hire we can't build these
ourselves so we have to get if figure
out a way partners can build those
things on zapier and at that point we
had enough inertia momentum from the
launch and from early users that were
really excited about the product and how
do you heard us jump start that see I
think that's like everyone especially I
remember back then to persona the
platform you got to be a platform like
how can you be like Salesforce and the
thing is jump-starting that is difficult
like just because you put up an API and
tell people like hey if you go and do
this then you're gonna get benefit like
there how did you guys in the early days
get people to be like I will program
against your thing
so that I can be part of your ecosystem
when it was very very small it is
interesting how every every SAS company
every software company eventually get
big enough you want to be a platform I
think I'd always I'd heard the heuristic
of like once you get big enough where
you could carve off 1% of your revenue
and that could be its own standalone
business like you've kind of reached a
critical mass that you could actually
build a platform that has legs and can
sustain itself for us in the early days
obviously we didn't have
I think the thing that we've leaned on
really heavily was the value proposition
to some of our partners building on
zapier it wasn't just but most of the
time these platforms plays one of the
big mechanics you see people building on
platforms is for distribution like I
might go want to be in the Salesforce
AppExchange because that way the more
Salesforce customers can learn about the
fact that I exist and might discover me
for us we didn't have that we didn't
have a big user base in the beginning
the value we gave to partners was around
retention if they built they integrated
with zapier they got access to 50 60 at
the time integrations that were
maintained and scaled and we're adding
more to it and they got a lot for free
oh so it allows them to go say to their
customers who are asking for these
integrations no longer do they have to
say hey sorry no we'll put that on our
to-do list or our future backlog and we
all know how that goes they could start
saying hey yes you can do that with our
product go check out SAP here here's a
link it was a way for them to say yes to
customer requests yeah like there's
actually way for you to do this go there
was value of them beyond you know just
user acquisition that incentivize in the
early days to build ins a beer didn't
end up being that like a lot of people
on the front lines like recommending you
or then support people because for us
like in our company customer support was
where all these feature requests would
come in and so did end up being I mean I
I would imagine a lot of them we're like
hey here's the stock guy here's how I
satisfy you
those are very common we get listed a
lot in like help docs health
documentation sales is also another
avenue where we get mentioned a lot
where we can zap your basically help
some close a deal with the customer that
they're trying to upsell or converting
to a paid plan
mm-hmm was that like the start of like
your dominance and like SEO stuff is
like oh we get people sort of linking to
us um the that was a little that was
actually earlier we so we built our app
directory before we load the product
before we launched in TechCrunch the
whole story was pre that we've been
burnt working on zapier for about five
months I think at that point yeah the
very first thing we did when we sat down
was we built our app directory which was
landing pages and we used that to try
and gauge what people wanted us to build
we were building these manually we
didn't we had a very big opportunity
cost on our time in the beginning how
how many apps did you guys integrate and
do before you actually had
people integrating and doing the work
it's like 50 or 60 yeah they get 50 or
60 yeah but we had landing pages for I
think a few hundred at that point and we
had email collection on the pages and
classic Lean Startup of just trying to
understand engage the market demand for
this thing before you go invest the time
to build it but on lunch you had 50 I
think so yeah because that was a
start-up weekend project initially yeah
yeah that's where I met Wade at actually
I meant Brian for about a year before we
started zapier but yeah I met way the
first time I was actually gonna pitch a
different idea at that Startup Weekend
yeah like I mean not even worth talking
about this point as soon as I heard
Brian pitched the idea for what was
called API mixer at the time my eyes lit
up and I was like that's what I'm
working on this weekend so during that
weekend we prototyped out actually
whatsapp here is it like to pick the
core mechanics of like mapping data
between apps all came out of that
weekend and I think we had we had we
built PayPal and high rises in Twitter I
think were the first three apps how did
you pick those it was more we sat down
and said what would be a cool use case
that we could demonstrate this prototype
with huh so during the final demo during
startup weekend if I went the mechanics
of the weekend as you work for a weekend
and then you present to the rest of the
crew on Sunday night and during the demo
we said hey we wouldn't be fun if we get
up on stage and have people actually
like tweet something live and then have
people pay us something on PayPal and
then you could actually see zap like the
prototype of zap your run and pull that
data into high rise the idea was like oh
we could aggregate you know if someone
pays you and PayPal and they're tweeting
at you you'd like to know that in your
CRM so that you could pay special
attention when you're contacting them so
it kind of came out of a single use case
and we worked backwards from that and so
at what point do you end up doing what I
see yeah we applied actually twice twice
II we got the email rejection the first
time we applied basically with the
prototype from Startup Weekend so we had
no customers no traction basically just
three DS from Missouri is a hackathon
project I hacked my project so totally
useful exercise I think but it
definitely lit a fire under us I think
as far as like what was wonderful about
filling out the clutter show these
people wrong did something change while
filling out the application it was
helpful to think through what we didn't
have yet I think for that first time
it made us realize some of the things
around traction that we were like there
was a big Delta and still like
optimistic with a prototype but yeah
once we got the email objection we at
that point we had enough hints of
success who were like we're gonna keep
working on this and it gave us actually
more motivation keep burning 40 hours
and nights and weekends a week for the
next few months and then the second plan
time we applied you know by that point
we had had hundreds of conversations and
chat logs and messages from actually a
lot of folks in like the YC network or
even using the product it was invite
only at that point we were having folks
pay we had our first ten people pay us
100 bucks
- like validate it and we turn down the
price like I think five bucks and we had
a few hundred people who paid us on
amount of money there's a lot more
social proof and validation that like
hey this is a problem that a lot of
people care about and could be useful
and so at that point had you guys
committed to being a fully remote
company when you went through YC did you
even have employees no just the three of
us and we hadn't zapier had been I
mentioned we've been doing nights and
weekends for that four or five months in
early 2012 they still had like jobs
yeah Brian awaited had full-time jobs I
was still full-time student actually a
grad student I I get the one the one
starving of dropping out it's a two-star
zapier but yeah after like our full-time
jobs were over you know five o'clock we
would go either back to our own
apartments and works up early or we've
had um one of our bosses let us run to
like use one of his offices to Co work
out of in the evenings and we'd go put
in you know work until midnight 1:00
a.m. every night working on zapier
basically so it's kind of two full-time
two full-time jobs for the first few
months yeah and so demo day happens and
then where do you go what do you do yeah
so after so obviously why Steve one of
the things is moving out to California
so that was kind of it was really I
think one of the big values of YC for us
we had a forcing function to go commit
Olin right no longer is it a side
project this is actually the full-time
now we could did you not fully believe
in it by then or is it like um you ever
thought like this is an interesting
hobby yeah I think you know thinking
back to the time it was you think about
our ambitions right it was like hey we
wanted to get this to a point where we
could spur our selves be our own bosses
control
schedule and hadn't got to the point
where we could supplant like our
full-time income so it was kind of out
of a necessity that we were running the
company that building it that way by two
planets we got to I see you know you get
a little bit of initial capital we got
an apartment in Sunnyvale and that kind
of allowed us to focus all full-time on
it after demo day we actually leading up
to demo day I remember one of the
problems early proms you ran into that
summer was all three of us would wake up
in the morning and we were all doing in
customer support we have a shared gmail
inbox like or not even that an email
would get copied into all three of our
inboxes in order to do support we would
have to sit next to each other and
wouldn't answer the same email and we
would be spending you know until noon
each morning just like answering support
tickets and trying to help people get
set up with the product and that was
chewing up a lot of development in Fort
progress time so the very first hire we
looked at was someone helps out with
support and we had no network in the Bay
Area we didn't you know we just moved
out three months ago we didn't know
anyone else our networks were from kind
of like our college networks and from
past jobs and when we started looking at
the folks we thought might be a good fit
for that the one person who came to mind
was one of Wade's I think college
roommates and he lived in Chicago at the
time and we know we couldn't convince
him to move to the Bay Area like we but
we didn't want to and it's not back to
like hey we were kind of doing zapier
remotely before start weekend or before
YC you like what's we could give that a
try and this coincided with the exact
time after YC where I was my wife
girlfriend at the time was finishing law
school back in Missouri so I was flying
back and forth every two weeks but back
to Missouri and then back out to
California to work Brian Wade so kind of
this perfect storm of like situation
where it was like well we have some
confidence that we can do this remotely
because we had been doing it before and
the people we want to hire one of your
moat and I had to be remote for part
part of the time so like let's just give
it a go so it was a very much an
experiment in early days just to think
like hey this was working let's see if
it can continue to work and did you have
any kind of plan or structure or we just
like yeah well let's just see what
happens and maybe work you know more
inspiration than plan I'd say like you
look at folks like Basecamp at the time
woohoo at the time like we had seen at
least small we're going to say
that had been successful at billing
fully distributed remote workforces so I
think there was more inspiration than
anything a lot of times for a lot of
people they feel like the company isn't
real until like there's an office
there's like a lot of ego Thera and so I
think that's the kind of thing that's
amazing about remote teams that actually
get really big is like somehow they
don't have something that's tied to like
the thing the thing I need to show off
like they're comfortable with saying
like I got no place to show you I work
from my home and so like is that an like
did you guys even struggle at all about
that it was like how are we going to be
a real serious company without this it
didn't hurt any it didn't like hurt any
efforts in terms of scale any
organization it certainly even it's
funny how much how pervasive that like
idea is because even I remember probably
last year or the year before we'd still
have people joining the organization who
could comment like yeah my parents want
to know if I'm working at a real company
right now and it's like well yeah we
have you know 100 with like 50 million
ARR like yeah we're a real company but
yeah it's still this one of the reasons
why I like some of the PR things would
be actually useful because we can send
those to friends and family and say hey
look with this this isn't just like a
side side show like this is a real how
did you not get caught into that trap
that's things like it has to come from
the founders obviously and so is it we
believe that it was not oh why is it
that you never felt like you needed to
have an office looks just like peer
pressure or a startup nor exactly like
why did you not subdue that because
that's often what I see a lot of people
do is that like I'm spending this money
because I think this is what it looks
like
to normalise me because this is actually
very especially at that time is very
radical to be like I'm not going to have
an office yeah I mean when we were
talking to like investors and whatnot
through YC lots that raised eyebrows
we'd get folks turning us away strictly
because of that even some of the folks
who did we went forward with like still
would be like hey when are you gonna you
know mature as an organization and get
an office and start hiring locally right
now do you see a very different opinion
in VCS so which is fun to see that
mindset shift but how did we were just I
mean in there a night
couple of first years between you know
2012 2014 it was largely driven out of I
guess kind of like the scrappy nature of
the organization like it was out of
necessity because we weren't profitable
yet we had only raised a small amount of
money to like help give us a backstop to
be able to scale a little bit faster
than we otherwise would have and the
networks of folks who wanted to hire
where there were remote it was probably
around eight or nine people into the
organization when it stopped being an
experiment
I do remember specifically having that
conversation will like Brian it weighed
around like hey this is this is working
like this doesn't it was probably I
think right after our first company
retreat where we went up to Washington
and had like seven of us then where it
felt like yeah this this isn't just like
an experiment and like an easy way to
get better recruiting like this is
actually a better way to like run the
company for us definitely started off
with a cost we're like we can't afford
an office but later on as things were
working we were just like yeah if you
have this frugal mentality were like
there's nothing about the office and
wanting to have a commute that made any
extra sense and we also had relocated
from California to Florida so it wasn't
like oh yeah our office in Florida was
going to be the driving yeah I think for
anyone and so you know us it really just
was like I think profitability was the
biggest thing for us like we were making
money and so if someone had some
criticism against like why are you doing
it this way I was like I'm making tons
of money so I don't really care what you
have to say about this right does we we
still have the best exit to investment
ratio ratio yes in terms of like how
much percentage of the company that YC
owned or any my angel investors if you
like the output and I think we're still
in like top 10 biggest exits for YC
still still because of how much equity
that was owned because we didn't raise
any money here is what we raised boys
and hard about $18,000 YC was $18,000
then and we raised money from to Angels
PB and PG and it was $50,000 age and I
was it I was just thinking you know I
think logistics and practicality was one
reason why promote was like we believed
in it so much there
the other reason I think is actually a
little bit more tied to like Brian Wade
and I how we'd like to work in the early
days like I think it goes back to this
that nights and weekends like part of
the reason inhibition we've of wanting
to like start zapping in the first place
was we kind of wanted to own our own
schedule and like set our own goals and
not be beholden to like a giant
organization telling us what to do we
wanted to be very autonomous and one of
like that that's a that is a company
value or number of values default to
action and that permeates all the way
from the very beginning where we wanted
to like we wanted to build zapier as a
company that we would want to work out
and if i'm gonna go work at it like a
big company i would want that like level
of autonomy and no one telling me that i
have to be in the office at 8:30 in the
morning every day and like control my
own schedule and be able to like just go
know go identify good things to work on
and do them so as someone now who's
hiring these people do you have to
filter out people who think that they
want that autonomy who think that they
might want to be working alone for
people who actually do and is there a
good way to do that like how do you get
the sense of its really good full of
like libertarians you care about freedom
or is it a company full of introverts I
imagine it's not one or the other but
it's one of those things where it's like
I do you think we probably attract folks
that enjoy working alone more not
exclusively we do have quite a few folks
who are extrovert in the organization
who've like been successful and found
ways to make it work one of the things I
tell everyone who's going through the
interview process is your work can't be
your family
it's a peer or an your distributed
remote company like you you in the past
it's very easy to lean on your work as
that like a social connection rare
healthy mind and if you if you're gonna
make it work at SAP here you have to
find a social network that's like
outside the company you'll get a little
bit of it because we do come to company
retreats you'll see their faces and
names all day and slack but whether it's
like you know like side projects or
hobbies or like close friends or
religion or family or whatever it is
like you'll definitely definitely want
to have one of those networks that's
outside the work environment related to
this like what are other major
characters that you look for that you
know this person is going to be
appropriate for a remote work past
experience of the remote is
good is a pretty good signal because
they know what they're getting into
wheat now with that said we've had quite
a few folks who haven't had post pass
remote experience and they've been very
successful but there is like a learning
curve attached to it I think the biggest
one of the biggest things I look for in
interviewing that tells me whether
someone's gonna be effective or not is
like how much they can uphold that first
value of like defaulting to action
do they have past experiences where they
did not take a consensus driven approach
and instead said hey this is the right
thing to do and I believe that this is
the right thing to do and went and
caused some kind of action in their
previous company or organization because
they thought it was the right but that
sounds like a call it is not just for
remote workers it sounds like you just
want that period for any company that is
one of the probably most surprising
things I have discovered or observed
scaling a 200-person remote company
today is that the types of things you
have to do in order to be a successful
remote company make you with just a
generally better company they are not
unique to remote however they you do
have to figure them out earlier and I
think then is where a lot of the
interesting when people ask like how do
you run a remote company I think that's
really where it is because that we've
had to invest really early on and how do
we what's our decision making frameworks
how do we communicate as an organization
what are our processes you have to get
really explicit about your processes in
order to be successful and in order for
folks to have the information that they
need to be able to default to action and
be able to know how to operate in this
organization so so you mentioned this I
heard this in another podcast about like
overlapping time zones and making sure
you don't unblock or block and unblock
people Neeta Mehta who I know hey Nina
asks a question on Twitter related to
this and that is what's the best way to
share work and knowledge across
designers working on different parts of
the product without distracting from
focused working time there's a
interesting underlying I guess
assumption here or observation all I
could say about this which is one of the
benefits of remote work apart like one
of the number-one benefits is of course
from recruiting you get the higher the
best p.p anywhere in the world a
secondary benefit that I think isn't as
obvious is that when you're actually
doing your job like the best work gets
done not when you're like sitting next
someone and like collaborating all day
there's like you have to get into deep
work even for a role like product design
which is very collaborative by nature
you still have to like have chunks of
time like four hours of the time to go
really deep and explore a lot of
iterations a lot of different ideas and
I think this is where like the process
part of the organization gets so
explicit is alright you know in a
co-located company in an office you
don't probably have a lot of explicit
direction or like process laid out as
far as when you're spending deep time
versus when you're collaborating and
coordinating with your coworkers because
I can just tap you on the shoulder Kevin
and like ask you what you think of my
the work I just did where is it a remote
team we just have to be so much more
explicit about what are the processes
individual people individual teams
follow when they want to communicate
what were some mistakes you guys made in
the early days you said you have to
figure this out early or daar um did you
guys make any mistakes I think one of
the things that we figured out in the
early days was when to be intentional
about how to be how to keep sounds
generic how to communicate when to raise
the bandwidth on communication there is
a when you're in a co-located
organization a company like I'm working
a person with you I the default
communication mode is I'm gonna get your
attention and then I'm going to have a
conversation with you and I have full I
have the full range of bandwidth right I
can use body language I can use my I can
stand up I can use tone it's like full
bandwidth between a split I've got 100%
distracted you like you I have your full
attention yeah now so it's like we're
taking two peoples times up with us in a
remote organization the default is a
hundred percent the opposite in the
spectrum which is people don't
communicate at all like if yours they're
using a slack channel and that's like
your main office which is how we operate
today if two folks aren't a team
together
the default is kind of like you don't
say anything it's a day it's like just a
blinking text cursor right um and we
have to be way to figure out when are
the right moments and how do we teach
the organization like when to move up
that bandwidth chain to move from not
talking at all because deep work is
important to text
is acceptable Slyke slack or email or
something like that to when to move that
to a video call
so like when should I raise the
bandwidth from like typing this thing
out to jumping on a video call and then
finally it's like write these rules down
there there's some like transition
moments to look out for I'd say and
those are the things that are like
written down and share with the company
so a good example of one that a lot of
folks would be familiar with is like the
slack many people are typing message
that pops up so if you like one of the
things a lot of her teammates if you see
that that's probably a really good
signal that you should be like jumping
on a video call at that point instead of
wasting or not wasting but instead of
spending you know 10 man-hours in slack
debating about this for an hour for
cross 10 people just get on the zoom
call and hash it out for 10-15 minutes
and then summarize the decision back
into the team chat tool that you're
using and it cuts down so it's like
that's kind of that's what I mean by
identifying the moments that it's
important to like increase the bandwidth
up to we had professed a rule when we
were doing remote working where we knew
that this was like really painful and
what we hated was long discussions
happening for too long and breaking this
sort of like deep work or like makers
schedule yeah and so for us we changed
the rule to be like if you're discussing
something for like 15 minutes at that
15-minute mark just you got to stop and
go on to whatever the next thing you
have to do like to get to like when you
say is default action and when we said
it like all discussions that have been
paused we had set a time for this and we
set it like at the end of the week on
Friday when the team meets together
it ended up being like 90% at a time
that once they slept on it they really
just have a discussion they view as like
they they just magically figure
something out or how to compromise or
realize something wasn't a big deal and
so usually by to help me get to Friday
not many things were ever brought up
only the most important things surface
exactly and so I think it was like I
like this idea that what you're trying
to default to is respecting someone
else's time and that the only time you
you start respect is when you like need
to make it really really efficient but
then what about on the other hand where
you're like say you're stuck on a
certain design problem programming
problem whatever it might be at what
point do you say like okay I'm gonna
break both of your focuses and take your
attention full
to solve this problem or try to solve it
yeah as a I mean it's a good question
that the reality is even if I wanted to
get your full attention there's no
guarantee you're gonna be able to get it
in a remote company right like I I may
not have a path where I can go over and
tap you on the shoulder I might be able
to you know DM you and slack I might be
able to send you a calendar invite and
hope to get ten minutes on your calendar
this afternoon but a lot of times you
don't have like you don't have the same
guarantee of being able to get someone's
attention that you do in a co-located
and I think that's actually good because
it protects the attention of the person
who would otherwise get distracted and
the thing like some of the social I
guess norms of the organization of how
we like address that is you know one is
in slack if you do if you tag somebody
in a message like at at tagging them
specifically it's kind of the social
norm to be to acknowledge that within 24
hours
so we have some expectations like then
the reason we had set 24 hours is
because we folks all across the world
the Sun never sets Sun zapier I like to
say so yeah we have some of these social
expectations where there is gonna be
some asynchronous 'ti in how the
organization works and operates and it's
one of the reasons why I think hiring
for default action is so important is if
you get blocked in whatever your primary
task is and you're waiting on someone
else in the org you have to have the
bone to go figure out what are other
smart things that I can work on that are
giving contribute value to the goals and
how to write better serve our customers
here yeah if you're the type of person
who like as soon as it get blocked I'm
just gonna sit here until I'm told what
to do next
you're not gonna be successful at zapier
or I'd argue most remote companies so
how big is a beer right now like how
many employees 200 which is 200 and then
your your primary responsibility is all
the design work that's done it's a peer
I spend a lot of time with our like
helping our product teams figure out
what to work on next and I love spending
time with our design and engineering
teams like how big is the product and
design team that's a very we've got
about seven or eight product managers a
similar number of product designers and
then an engineering or that's about 50
folks attached to that
so from my experience I know like how
much collaboration is necessary like
associate the start of like building out
new products and sort of like thinking
through them and then also designing
them and then also part of like the
design culture is like critiques and so
to me that was one of the things that
was like really difficult luckily at
roof it was like I was the only designer
or never grew to beyond 10 people so you
to communicate with yourself exactly so
we never ran into the problem really
curious is like what did you what's done
differently for your design team and
product team yeah to make that sort of
work yeah I think the one of the most
important relationships in the
organization is the relationship within
product managers and product designers I
don't think I'm saying anything newer
now well here by saying that but it's
certainly true for us which is when we
are thinking about staffing and hiring a
team we're making sure that those two
folks have are like intentionally
building rapport they're spending a lot
of time together and they have a very
strong shared ownership over the goals
that they're working towards and won't
do that remote work wise that's the
thing that's difficult especially when
you're trying to respect everyone's
bandwidth yeah yeah in the in the
earlier days when we had started scaling
which we'd started kind of scaling these
teams maybe about a year or two ago
it was I'll admit it was more ad hoc
like we were figuring out this process
still these days with 200 we've been a
lot more we just have someone who was
talking about before we have to scale a
lot more explicit with processes we
started using oak hours as like an
alignment mechanism and like a designer
and a PM and an engineer all own and
share an okay right if the companies can
have weird definitions of Oh care it's
like how do you guys to find okay ours
like an objective that that team is
trying to accomplish like hey we want to
you know increase how many users are
able to set up as app by 10% this
quarter or something like that and
that's something that a p.m. and a Jing
manager and a product designer would
have shared ownership over and that for
it gives like gives a lot of focus to
that team and it also gives the it kind
of helps elevate everyone's role to be
thinking about like the impact in the
customer first I think what the thing
I've noticed that happens in scaling
zapier is there's a tendency for
engineering at p.m. design to kind of
specialize in their own areas and like
they have their own unique things are
thinking about all the time right
engineer might be
all day and about the user experience
and engineering is thinking all day
about estimates and delivery and
refactoring in code quality PM is think
about business impact and if you don't
give them some kind of if there isn't
some kind of shared system for how they
should value the things that are
prioritizing you get a lot of us versus
them mentality that kind of creeps into
the organization where it's like whoa I
want the designer do this around with
the engineer do this so you give teams
ok ours versus individuals yes gotcha
yeah this is something we're new we're
starting to do but so far it's been
pretty fruitful in building that like
alignment across teams and so how is the
team checking in on each other is it
like a stand up type thing yeah
everything goes a little different
actually so there's a lot of expen of
the things about zapier that is cool to
see is a lot of teams experiment with
some of the process you give a lot of
autonomy to different teams to try a
bunch of stuff yes we do um ok no cars
are kind of our framework for how we
pull Oh make that not chaotic if that
makes sense sorry I like to think about
there's like the things that are
important to be consistent across teams
are the interfaces like you need to make
sure that the interface between teams is
consistent so that both teams know how
are you specific what does that mean
what's our how am i dependent on you or
what is the API layer if it's two
product teams that are building in the
same area of the product ok or if it's
design what's the like ownership between
where's that handoff like what's the
scope role scope of ownership between
two teams so it's like or to be another
layer it might be like if we use a
breeze JIRA for doing a lot of our issue
tracking a project management and it's
there is some level of consistency that
is important to have across all of our
product teams using our project
management software so that we can build
some observable observability into the
product development process across the
whole company so we can get a sense of
like where are we doing well where are
we not doing well identifying issues
where we might be over investing in
feature work or under investing in
feature work or tech debt and things
like that so there's like some level of
consistency that's important but we do
generally try to give a lot about
individual autonomy to these like epd
trios so how the teams created mostly
onin like do you guys assign them or the
people kind of like have a draft or they
are picked and like we hire into them
I guess so we
will create a lane at the like
leadership level of the organization
like hey here is a new opportunity we
want to go after here's a new area the
product that we aren't addressing or
part of the conversion funnel that we
want to improve and will then staff into
that so we've got a decent recruiting
team now so whatever team that someone's
on they kind of stay with that team all
the way through the life of zapier or
it's mostly their long running teams
I'll say that we've had folks which I
wouldn't say we've etched our earliest
product team is only two a year and a
half two years old so well and some of
those folks have shifted we've had stuff
folks reached out from one team to
another where there was like another
part of the product they wanted to work
on and they had some expertise that
could be used somewhere else maybe we
brought in you know maybe this person's
like a really senior level experienced
at engineering and we've just brought in
like more of a staff or associate level
engineer we want to like it but work
together what's the timeframe for like
these okrs like are they of like
quarterly goals like yearly goals like
you probably have a range of them yeah
annual an annual and monthly tends to be
the two kind of extremes annual just to
know if like all right where are we what
are we working towards over the course
of year what is this product team trying
to accomplish over the course of 2019
and then kind of monthly check-ins
against that where they break those down
and so can you break down how an average
team might handle tracking for a new
care like how does that work flow
actually go down yeah this is still new
to the organizations so I feel like I
need to give the coffee epithet yeah
we're learning a lot still with this
we've been practicing with oak hours at
the exact level for the last two
quarters in 2018 which gave us enough
confidence that hey this is actually a
very effective tool for us to help align
and allow everyone all these different
teams and people in the organization to
be autonomous and default to action and
ways that they want that we wanted to
start rolling it out to all the
individual teams this year for 2019
practically speaking I think the best
version of this and this is aspirational
I don't think we're quite there yet is
you've got some high level of direction
being set by the leadership of the
organization what are we trying to
accomplish right for a pure case we're
trying to build a piece of productivity
software that anyone can use how do we
get zapier adopted by you know
millions of people Sunday and you've got
this high-level direction and strategy
being set and then at the team level and
lower in the organization there's a lot
of work that is happening that needs to
figure out okay where is that aligned
and how does that bubble up and there's
kind of a meet in the middle
approach where you kind of want for the
work that's happening fifty percent of
it to be kind of top-down driven and I
think 50 percent of it being bottom-up
because in reality the exact team
leadership is never going to have
perfect insight into all the pieces of
work that happen across the organization
and I don't think that's what something
like okar is is particularly useful for
us to define every piece of work you're
doing I think it's largely useful for
helping you prioritize and make hard
trade-offs and have discussions like
this is one of the things that's great
about writing down our process
documentation and zappy you're writing
down our decision-making processes is
when it's written down you have
something to debate about I can go to
you and say hey can we debate whether
this is the right thing we should be
spending our time on it's so much easier
to do that when there's an artifact that
you're talking about as opposed to a
group of people like with different
ideas in their head about what is
important to have it it just removes
this layer of like conflict in the
organization it also discussions can
drift when it's not like tied to the
artifact yeah what other tools do you
guys use like I don't have any doubt
that you guys just like use a per itself
to help you guys we are yes you use okay
our dog for you but I remember in the
early days talking to you guys you guys
bought a lot of tools for yourself and
I'm just wondering like right now what's
like the most helpful tools that you
guys are using either that you've built
yourself or that like other that you're
using from other companies yeah the one
that I actually built this one in the
early days it's a tool called async it's
what the name of it internally it's an
internal blog essentially we use slack
as kind of our company office for a
better for worse like this is where
folks usually log in to in the morning
this is work work gets talked about
we've got about one of the trouble with
that especially as we scaled and anyone
any remote company or any team that uses
slack will be able to tell you this it
gets the overwhelming amount of noise
and slack how do you keep up with slack
and we're very early on we set the
expectation that slack is not a tool
you're expected to keep up
than zapier you are free to leave
channels in fact we encourage it that is
fascinating
there's a feature in slack where you can
turn off the leave join notifications
and we turn that off because we wanted
to give folks likes great the social
comfort to be able to leave channels
without feeling awkward just cuz it
feels like pressure it's like they're
behind on my homework there's some
social prenda muting those channels
rather than leaving them yes yeah like
we actually have like a course working
on for how to like bees effective it
using slack you happier but this is an
early day so we so we'd set that
expectation of that's how we use that
tool one of the things that kind of was
missing that I saw was what what is our
like more thoughtful tease me like the
Daniel Kahneman idea like slow thinking
version of slack like slack is where
work gets talked about right it's like
quick responses in the moment I need a
decision okay where does our final work
get talked about her where does our more
like deeper work that we're thinking
more long-term and putting together like
where our final reports getting shown to
the organization and how does that get
shown to how do the right people get
notified that like I have something I
need you to read and make a decision are
to think about so those were the early
days I actually got inspired by Nick
Francis over at help scout they were
using a tool another remote team called
p2 was a plugin for WordPress that it
was basically it's kind of like a
Twitter feed yeah automatic was using
this internally and that's how they run
their the old it is yeah we we worked we
used it as a pure for good six months
and it was pretty good it started
breaking and we wanted to customize it
and this is one of the most interesting
things I've why I like investing in
tools is you can you can tweak and
change them to match the like level of
company you're at essentially imagine
company gets bigger gonna run into these
new bottlenecks and you can start like
layering in and customizing the tool
instead of having to go like throw the
tool and pull a new one in and relearn
it so this in the early days PT started
breaking for us it didn't scale it
didn't tie into our office system was
funny enough the reason why I wanted to
rebuild it so I built a version of
internally called async which can just
internal blog and this was kind of the
tool that what one of the cadences we
have and zapier is every week we ask
everyone right if right up
for what they worked on this is kind of
the heartbeat of the organization and so
that goes up on the blog it goes up on a
sink yeah and this work crew loved it
like in the early days you got 20 people
30 people you get to read everybody's
Friday updates you can't know everything
that's every decision that's made
everything people are learning all the
work that's happening well you get to 70
or 80 100 blog posts yeah that starts
taking a full day just to read like all
the information so let's you start to
run into the same problems even slack
does where it's information overload
yeah but because we own the tool we can
we can tweak it and tailor it to how we
like are we want to run the organization
and how we make decisions and how we
want communication to work we started
building like a default feed view where
it was a curation layer in terms of okay
who are your immediate direct reports
who are the folks you need to follow you
can follow folks you can create custom
feed views to like build the curation we
work with managers to like onboard new
employees to set up there like views in
the right way so that it's curated so
that they get that might just the
information they need and so does email
have a specific role or is it kind of a
catch-all free don't send any internal
email really that's like my fantasy
full-stop then we so we use email emails
using a few sways in zapier it's we of
course we do email support so we just
help Scout and all of our emails
basically if there's any internal to
external communication so like when
we're talking our partners or with
customers obviously that happens over
email yeah but internally there is lack
and async yeah those are a tool we have
one we also use quit for a long term
like long-form documentation it is a
wiki it's a collaborative wiki kind of
Google Docs mixed with a wiki and that's
more for like documentation yes yeah
documenting processes hiring rubrics
things that kind of need to live a
little bit longer in the organization
both async and slack our feed views that
roll off one thing people were surprised
about with us at with it was like how
much time we spent development wise on
internal tools actually it was like
almost like 30 to 40 percent of our like
development time was like I was building
stuff for ourselves it's why we were
able to grow and only be at like a 10
person company office or so long and so
like what is that ratio for you guys and
I do you have special
internal tools teams like you know the
Facebook is kind of famous for we we did
last year we had invested in internal
sodium which was helping scaling some of
the async software that we were talking
about I fir better worse have been kind
of the internal tools my head over the
last six months I was building mid to
this oak cars we actually built our own
okay our software into async gotcha
and one of the beautiful beautiful parts
of it is like when you're updating your
okay are it's got annotations that tie
into the poster writing so we've got
this nice long-running graph of hey
here's this metric I'm moving over the
year you can see oh here's where we
launched this feature here's where we
made this decision and you can see it
annotated on the graph and but right now
it's kind of just organic like keys make
their own stuff like it does tend to be
a little more organic I'll say in the
early days I think we invested more time
and internal tools and it's something
I'd love to spend more time on actually
like I was just thinking just listening
to a singer like I know remember this
for us like a lot of our internal tools
I ended up being like YC companies down
the line of the future as I am i hearing
a sea-can were just like oh god that's a
startup right there more more recently
most of the internal things that get
built in zapier today are like apps on
zapier we have a lot of folks in our
engineering team and even more broadly
on a support team and the product dazeem
that where we'll build features into
zapier by building an app on zapier and
this is kind of where some of like the
innovation of zapier comes from is like
quite a few of the most popular apps on
zapier were built by like one engineer
and a side project at like a retreat
hackathon just for fun because it was
like hey we're gonna add this little bit
of functionality to the product that
doesn't exist
maybe it's the ability actually meted
out in the product yeah it's actually
the biggest criticism for lots of
corporate hackathons is like people
spend all weekend get really excited
they never make it to the life day yeah
we tried pretty hard to make like pick
our packet on projects and we curated
them in a way that we thought that there
was some value that could eventually
make it to the make it out to customers
in some format or would help customers
in some way so what are the other things
you guys do to kind of keep employee and
founder morale high across the remote
team yeah we do the probably the biggest
thing we do is we do two company
retreats a year even the fact even
though we're 100 percent remote there is
still a lot of value for getting in
person
we don't like discount that yeah you get
to build a lot of empathy you get to
build relationship with folks and it
allows you to kind of be assume best
intent the rest of the earth right when
you're when you're in slack and you're
on that working on that tense project
and someone we use you know writes a
message that might be a little more Curt
than it should have been it's like oh I
can hear their voice on my head like I
know that is I understand who that is
like I'm not gonna jump off and like
assume that yeah they were trying to be
mean to me or something like that and
that helps smooth over a lot of issues
that I think can happen when you are
primarily using text-based communication
tools where you do lose a lot of that
tone you have to try like really hard to
use tone and it's just that's one of the
first things that can easily get lost
when you're like in tense moments so
there's a lot of value for building
in-person relationships still so we do
two company retreats a year where we
find the whole company into usually some
quarters order hotel or place around the
USU George how long are those restraints
so for a week and then in the Friday
what do you guys do during that time is
it just hanging out or I mentioned
structure yeah we've tried a few formats
we've mentioned hackathon we've
traditionally done like a hackathon most
of the week and then we would have a
couple days set up for teams to kind of
break out in their own individual silos
this past retreat which I had something
different though we tried giving one of
the things we do a lot we run a lot of
company surveys and we try to evolve and
iterate how we run them doesn't mean you
do a lot like how often I mean any time
we're doing a company-wide thing there's
probably gonna be a survey sent out
about like it to get feedback so we can
approve it for next time okay email uh
it is tied into slack actually I do but
there is an email though - I wouldn't
that yeah I still I still do keep my
gmail tab open by either there is like a
slack time but we ever company retreat
there's a survey we sent out to company
servers a year I ran a product all
company survey last year so we do a lot
of that what's the best thing you guys
do at the retreat that you didn't do it
on the first ones like what has changed
that you're like this is way better to
do it this way I so this last time the
thing week
Behrman with was we added unstructured
time we had always planned every hour of
every retreat to date where hasn't it I
know this you didn't think about it
earlier right it's probably a bias
that's like or being like thinking we're
in a remote line site right which is
like design the process how do we want
people collaborating how do we want them
connecting what and like make that
happen and I think some of our like you
know managers feel responsible to make
sure their teams are taken care of and
people know what they're doing and what
they're should be spending time on so
there was just the sense where from the
top from management perspective like
we're over planning all the hours and
one of the things that that prevents is
cross team coordination or cross team
communicate conversation or what if like
one person from the data team and one
person from support and one engineer
like had this cool topic that they
talked about it may be one of our
unconference sessions they wanted to go
hack on an idea like there was no time
for that to happen in the past format
and it should because we it was
completely tapped out planned so we
added these two afternoon sessions of
unstructured time where we set the
expectation that hey it's still a
workday but figure out how to best
utilize this time with your team and
your peers how do you know it worked
well mostly through feedback at this
point I I was anxious about going in
like it was so we design we added this
process in because of feedback we gone
before I want time like people have
specifically asked for time to do this
so we added it in I was still anxious
that like folks would not take advantage
of it I was worried that they would just
default to what they would do if they
weren't at the retreat right
just do what like I'm gonna go do your
normal works and I work on my roadmap or
work on support tickets in isolation
what we want take advantage of the fact
we're here so I over emphasized in
almost all my conversations with the
team leading up to the tree to like take
advantage of the time and when I walked
around and just observe the different
groups of people that were court-like
coordinating in those afternoon sessions
I was surprised at how many people took
advantage of the time like given my
anxiety I guess that it was not I think
it should be surprising when you're
hiring a bunch of people who are like
default action self-driven etc and then
you bring them all together like think
right thing yeah it certainly worked out
well and I will continue to do something
like that and future treats I I think we
talked about I'm curious like how do you
guys do design critics like how does
that work in this collaborative art is
it so difficult you know like to even do
it in person
yeah and so like how do you and you guys
have an interface that has to bridge
hundreds and hundreds of apps together
and hundreds of hundreds of different
types of features together and so it's
so complex and I'm trying to think of
like doing that without people really
close and diving deep on the problem
like how does that work for you guys I
guess I'd be interested to ask like why
what assumption do you have that makes
why what like previous belief or
experience do you have Kevin that says
like I have to be sitting next to you in
order to solve a problem like that I
think it's one of those things where
like for design in particular I it's
hard to like point circle re-sketch etc
those are some things that like on pen
and paper in person I can show now I
know that there's ways to do it where
it's like oh I can do this show it by
video etc but it seems slower and more
inefficient I'm just wondering like is
there things that you could do to
compensate or as I say you think about
it differently yeah it comes back down
to being explicit again so one of the
exercises I've done quite a few times
with the team has been like the nine box
design exercises what time I fold your
paper into like nine boxes and you have
like two minutes to sketch nine
different ideas of a solution and then
you have every one percent there nine
ideas and then you like a remix usually
a for like a longer five-minute session
and actually come out with a lot of just
divergent ideas in a short amount of
time and the time compression on being
able to come up with an individual is
intentional to like force folks not to
get too deep and the thinking just like
go wide instead of deep i've run these
over zoom calls where i'll literally ask
i did this with the entire company last
year where a little while ago where
asked was like maybe the point 70 or 80
people everyone bring paper bring
sharpie and I gave the problem statement
up front and everyone's like just on a
zoom call with their video I like
sitting on the table
and draw another paper and they'd hold
it up and they talk about it and I had
them take a picture and post in the
slack channel so there was like a higher
fidelity version that they could see and
they're holding it up and pointing to it
I actually see how that's stronger than
normal design collaboration when
everyone's in a room there's a pressure
of like no I can't I don't want to look
bad or like if I'm trying to sketch and
figure something out like it feels
uncomfortable to do so in front of a
bunch of other people so I can see how
like having everyone separate it's like
oh you're working in your own kind of
say it feels a little bit more safer to
be daring yeah and there's like there
were instances where I remember still
having to like encourage folks like hey
show it even if you think it's like bad
because that's some of some of the
things you think are weird ideas often
end up leading to the right idea even if
they're initially like weird will just
trigger like a different way of thinking
about a problem that hasn't been thought
of before but we've so another process
we have in addition to like doing kind
of team exercises like this one of our
more go-to processes that we've been
working really well for us the last last
year was we were doing a a Tuesday
Thursday essentially design review
across several product teams so we would
invite several product managers several
product designers and the Tuesday
Thursday cadence was how we built in
that feedback we process where it's like
okay I want to show something the team
and get feedback on it get critique and
then it's instead of only doing one a
week where you have to wait a whole
nother cycle there's a forcing function
to turnaround and iterate and go deep on
48 hours to then turn around and show it
back on Thursday that's the end showed
again so it's it's kind of like a bit of
a mix where you still get that deep work
in between the two review check-ins but
it's still in a zoom call well one of
the things I like to ask people to do
and zoom calls especially in design
collaboration sessions is like don't
mute yourself
zap ears built up this interesting norms
around like how what what is zoom
etiquette right like how did when done
with yourself when to like jump on video
all that kind of stuff so we kind of I
have to like intentionally ask folks to
like break that habit and say okay for
this please don't give you a mute so to
encourage folks is jump in right I want
folks to feel comfortable not waiting to
give their feedback but just like
to generate a little bit more like
randomness in that conversation I think
this is probably one of the things that
is very interesting about remote and you
there's a question someone asked around
like how do you be innovative as a
remote company or how do you and there's
some amount of like randomness that you
I think is probably desirable in an
organization certainly you don't want it
to be 50 or a hundred percent random
rikey you you want some low level of
like it's randomness in terms of people
talking to each other or what's being
shared yeah I think they're kind of
alluding to like serendipitous chance
encounters right weird like you know
water cooler conversation yeah one of
the things we do is process be that's
called the pair buddies we're actually
three people in these now I've gotten
big enough where we've a bot that
randomly just picks people that are in a
slack channel and says hey tooth people
should there are three folks now should
like here's thirty minutes to chat okay
the idea is like you don't know agenda
just like a thirty minute call over to
share whatever you're working on and
talk to you some of those ideas I
actually think this idea is interesting
I actually think a lot of companies or
organizations a group over optimized for
serendipity like they're like what about
that chance phone but to me like
serendipity like we're like some random
thing happening all of a sudden have a
great idea
like that's like hitting the lotto and
to me optimizing for the lotto is very
weird
99% of companies like we have a whole
list of [ __ ] that we have to get done
and so to me it's like optimizing for
that should always be the first priority
not for the off chance of these other
chance encounters I'm always wondering
like what is the right ratio because I
think there is some I think back to our
hackathons right where this is a totally
individual driven thing and we had great
things that got built that no one would
have liked top-down plan to go build and
surprised us like in terms of how
popular it became but I think it works
out better when you build up a kind of
pressure and then it needs like a
release yeah like where all of a sudden
is like oh this is my opportunity right
versus like yeah well not forcing it
just like oh let's like have it all
together and then maybe something will
sort of bubble up I mean to me like a
lot of it ends up getting solved by just
knowing what other people are working on
which is a problem across every company
I've never worked at before so I have no
idea what Kevin's done
the past two weeks right like I know
Kevin's don't been on the pot Kevin's
like crush an email but what have you
actually been doing we we don't have
that problem we have the other other
problem which is like I have too much
there have too many opportunities to
learn whether the people working on it's
like how do i curate down to like
alright who are the people I need to
know about what's working on so that I
am doing my job effectively so kind of
wrapping up I'm curious about like if I
were to be starting out a remote company
what's the framework you would offer to
say like okay you should do XY and Z
things and set yourself up for success
to really get the most out of this I
think it is one of the reasons why it is
so hard to add remote onto an existing
company is because remote well when you
see folks to talk about it and ask
questions about it's always very
processing tools based I think the
honest answer is that it's more of a
cultural change than it is a process and
tools thing so folks that are starting
out actually how I think are at an
advantage in this fact because there is
no culture yet like it is you or uses
your you know co-founders or whatever
and you have the chance to like set up
the culture in a way that encourages
things that are going to work in a
remote organization so again thinking
through things like defaulting action
and encouraging empowering autonomy and
how are we going to make decisions and
thinking through some of those things in
the early days being exposed about
writing down and sharing all the work
that you do and building it a habit into
the organization to write down
everything that's done and share that
with colleagues as opposed to relying on
context sharing over like a zoom call
that's a ephemeral and can get lost that
those who like the cultural habits and
norms they're a lot harder to change in
the future because you need everybody
doing them I think there's a structural
advantage for folks that are a hundred
percent distributed that everyone's in
an equal boat they're all in the same
boat right I'm all in my home office if
other people aren't doing that thing
then I'm not going to be successful
happy in my my own job so you can take
advantage on the early days by like it's
a lot easier to set those that initial
culture up where it's like okay we we do
want folks to be individually empowered
to make
decisions we want to hire folks that
have like demonstrated this ability in
the past we want folks that are good at
written communication that like over
communicate even like one of the things
I often tell new engineers that are
joining zapier and product designers is
I have to encourage our communication a
lot again coming back to the default no
one talks like it is more important and
it feels awkward at first to like be
just sharing a status update with like
an empty slack channel or a slack
channel where you're not expecting a
reply like that takes a habit to build
where it's like you have to realize how
useful that is to the person on the
other end where hey I might get blocked
on something that status of do you gave
four hours ago helps give me some
context on something that I'm should be
doing or how to solve a problem in a
certain way that otherwise would get
blocked on but you know request response
cycle from them and especially across
time zones that stuff so yeah be just
setting up the right values around like
autonomy and written communication are
probably the two most important you guys
wrote a book about this right I know we
did yeah it's a book on running a remote
company it's a couple I think it's a
couple years out of date from a process
standpoint but it gets like the cultural
what's the biggest right yeah what's the
biggest thing you wish you could update
in the book so like one I mean the
biggest thing probably how we've scaled
async would be what I would go back and
like to add to it and you're like the
book was written at a time where we did
we had enough people that could somewhat
reasonably consume all the context that
was published there on a on a monthly
basis or on like a daily basis or weekly
basis that's not true anymore like we've
had to be a lot more and thoughtful and
intentional about what are the is it a
push first poem kind of mechanism
what's the deep what's the kind of
algorithm that powers the default feed
view that shows content that everybody
should be reading in the organization on
a weekly basis and then water like
thought leaders and other people in this
space that you guys follow for and like
inspiration that other people should
definitely check out yeah there's
several folks that are bigger than us
that have run robot organizations kind
of a little bit of rare error once you
get beyond like
50 people though or even 20 people fully
remote folks like it lab is bigger than
us envision is another organization
that's largely remote automatic is
another early one that we looked up to I
think the biggest thing again we took
away from those was not from not a
process standpoint or even a cultural
value standpoint it was hey it exists
this is not impossible right like
someone has proved that it is possible
we are not having to trailblaze the fact
that like it is possible to have a
company with that many people that's
fully remote now they have slightly I'm
all those organizations have slightly
different value mechanism we do so like
that's what we're going to figure out as
we scale is all right how does that how
do we apply that size of the
organization to where we're at but yeah
that's the biggest takeaway I would say
is like remote is possible there's very
large organizations that are doing it so
you're in good company if you decide to
build a fully remote company that's a
great place to wrap it up alright thank
you thanks Craig thanks really
you